let's play shiamando i think subbed
earlier this stream
never played before
i think shayamando said they have like
staffer gambit crap
i saw some offhand comment earlier
stafford gambit time part two
um yeah h3 is a move
a tree is recommended by a lot of people
ooh and queenie too
okay so i'll play bishop d4
it seems like white knows what they're
doing
yeah i've i've encountered this probably
a few times it's a weird configuration
queen e2 knight d1 it's playable though
so i think what i'll do is play
how crazy do i want to be see maybe i'll
play bishop e5 first
with c5 there is e5
oh that's also playable maybe
no no e5 would actually probably win a
piece for white
so i'll play this
and now c5
so i prevent d4
i'm just trying to get a position i can
work with
this is not a typical maneuver in
stafford to play bishop
d4 to e5
oh f4 is a threat
okay there is kind of a funny line h4 f4
knight h5
takes knight here
which actually looks kind of playable
so let's do it oh no my bishop
i'm gonna be giving white three center
pawns
but i'll get uh
i'll get a fork
the question i see did queen b5 win upon
i can address that later
but first thank you to john bartholomew
what's up john
shout out to john
reading with 177
if you're just joining we have a a weird
staffer gambit
right before the raid i played this and
said oh no my bishop
but white yeah white chose not to take
it
i think i still play knight g3 here
and just enjoy the outpost
oh the minnesota raid
yeah hey guys it's not john
it's eric but thanks john
john has a cool emotes
okay i feel like i'm about to suffer
for those just joining i'm playing
viewers a stream the game before this i
had a really
nice feel good stafford
but this is kind of a feel bad stafford
let's just retreat white's going to
maybe expand further
if e5 i get the f5 square
also this bishop moved here here here
here here getting a lot of exercise
so i'll play c6 ensuring that when i
develop this there's no queen b7
okay now this bishop wants to get some
exercise
hey puns of steel gifting to john
appreciate that
yeah knight f2
it neutralizes my bishop
also maybe it prepares this
could take
there's almost a really funny line
involving queen d4
pawn d4 bishop b4 doesn't work at all
because king d1
which kind of makes me want to play this
move
but there's other moves too there's c5
let's play this move it's such a weird
[Music]
move
oh there's a funny line but
it requires only one requires a move
no my queen oh no my queen
ah oh lee chess will restart in nine
minutes
oh shyamando how shy are you going to be
here
i didn't think it was going to happen
all right white's not gonna take it
because
i should have said da my queen
[Music]
yeah so the funny line is pawn takes and
then bishop before his mate
which is a really cool mate it only
worked after bishop d3
because it blocked the queen from
accessing c3
unfortunately we just traded and i
didn't really
get much out of that
play queen c4 got some content though
i tried to play this quickly to make it
seem like i'm i don't know some kind of
pre-move mouse loop
yeah so taking is legal but um vision
before would be mates
i think oh now i can take the pawn
i think this king is less safe even
though it's castled
oh how many people believed it
oh i could castle with chuck
also just play this
preserve castling for later
oh there's a funny line there's so many
funny lines this game
[Music]
okay i'm down a little bit of time i'm
losing back upon
oh no my pawn but now i castle so this
is a the castle fork
don't see this too often it's a
surprisingly legal move
because uh the king doesn't move through
check and
you you're okay moving the rook through
a square that's attacked
yeah this is very rare where you can
attack the king and the rook
simultaneously i still have to be
careful though
because i'm about to flag and my king is
slightly naked
it has a little bit of clothing though
and there's so many funny lines this
game another line is takes
um let's uh let's try and get the sign
so king will move back probably
and the line is takes if queen takes i
pin
and if king takes i i would have checked
king e3 and bishop c5 mate
okay a few things to show after this
game
[Music]
10 seconds to meet
fun game though a lot of craziness this
game
[Music]
oh it's a nice mate it's another one of
these
what dovetail type things thanks for the
game shiamando
definitely played an interesting opening
and not too many people
know know about this setup like h3
queen 2 knight d1
there's other more normal approaches
like d3
sooner most people play d3
but
yeah i play bishop d4
it's typical move like usually white
will still continue with d3 and
try and get the setup but after this
white is clearly going for
c3 d4 so try to play preventively
there was a question earlier if queen b5
just wins upon
which it might i have 97
i would have thought here like whether
to to play c6 and
gambit more
i guess 97 apparently is better but yeah
engine likes white here
and then yeah then things got weird
um so right before white played bishop
d3 i realized that if bishop d3 i could
take
so i was ready to take even though this
doesn't win anything it's kind of uh
it's fancy is queen d4 the best move
oh it is oh wow
one of the best moves it's just such a
crazy
occurrence that like because the king's
in the center usually it has a lot of
squares to go to
but my pieces are placed in such a way
that light would be mated
um and then i'll show one more thing
yeah of course the castle fork is nice i
could have castled sooner
maybe should have but
nice tactic you don't get every day
and then the final sequence
rook d3 so
this is a actually when we got to this
position i was already calculating rook
d3
and the point the bishop can't take
because it's pinned
in the game the queen took and the queen
got pinned if king takes there's
this and this would be kind of a fancy
mate
bishop c5 so knight is remarkably well
placed
along with a rookie bishop anyway okay
i hope people enjoyed that game maybe
i'll put that on youtube
and dedicate it to john bartholomew hi
to youtube
rook b7 save the queen
oh there's rook b7 here good point
oh i could have been in trouble
black is still for a choice but the time
situation would have been difficult
yeah deflecting my king from defending
the pin
the uh the pinning piece and if this
there's rook b8
so i would have had to take okay it's
still winning
i guess i would have had to endure this
position
[Music]
okay thanks for that maybe i'll include
that in the video
and yeah reminder to like and subscribe
and by merch